chocolate
since the first fire users Flex video
gained so much positive feedback we're
back for round two you know those scenes
that make you go wow went ouch at the
same time so without further Ado let's
get into the second set of moments when
fire uses in anime flexed on their
opponents blitzing into the list we have
the Lioness Mario Leona versus her
punching bag Rya from Black Clover
all right
before the fight ryer was heavily
established to be a threat due to his
immense magic power and with his
Transformation Magic he proves to be an
opponent that not anyone should take
lightly well that is after he faces off
against Mario Leona and right off the
bat Mario Leona blitzes forward with
blinding speed hitting him straight in
the face yes Ryan might have had the
upper hand due to the flexibility of his
magic using the appropriate spells in
the situation which is in this case
water magic and Mario Leona being the
badass that she is just opted to take
the attack head on after all there's no
need for mere tactics if you just turn
up the heat and turn it into steam
despite Raya changing up his angle of
attack Mario Leona's sheer power and
strength just burst right through it
even foiling his last-ditch effort by
copying our star's sword let this be a
lesson for Raya to never again look down
on the indomitable will that humans are
capable of now
oh
yeah what we have next is escanor versus
Esther Rosa from seven deadly sins
if we're talking about flexing then you
can count on escanor for this guy it's
just a literal walking and talking Flex
his very existence is to flaunt his
pride and there's absolutely nothing you
can do about it since this man has the
skills and power to back it up and that
was truly showcased in his fight against
Esther Rosa his quotes are enough of a
flex on their own but what comes after
is what truly matters as he summons
cruel sun which then proceeds to easily
Blow Away Esther Rosa with minimal
effort and in the ensuing fight despite
Esther Rosa using blackout to cancel out
escanor's cruel son his efforts were for
nothing in the end as escanor's Pride
simply won't allow it he then simply
Shrugged it off and hit him dead center
with his cruel son burning him to a
crisp in the whole series this man has
done nothing but kick ass defy the odds
and flex whilst he's at it and we
certainly love him for it now you may
disagree that he's a fire user and to
that I'd say who decided that
coming up next karna versus seek from
one of the most chronologically
confusing series fate
all right
we have arguably one of the most heated
and destructive fights in the whole show
here after all if we're talking about
fights that are of destructive
proportions then this fight definitely
Takes the Cake a fight so destructive
that Maps were probably redrawn because
of the aftermath we were treated to a
front row seat in this fight as we
witnessed literal gods and legends duke
it out and fight for what they believe
in Ghana was clearly shown to be the one
winning in this fight as he deforms the
landscape and turns them either into
Rubble or molten magma while slowly
driving sieg into his limits Garner was
able to drive the fight in his favor as
he used his Noble Phantasm vasavi Shakti
to put an end to the fight but alas
victory was not for him to claim but we
do have to keep in mind it took Achilles
shield and Frankenstein's galvanism just
to squeeze out a victory for sieg but
that's besides the point here the sheer
Display of Power that Garner has shown
us was enough of a flex on its own but
the story can't go on if the main
character is dead after all this Victory
he had to give to someone else a true
hero of Charity indeed continuing the
nuclear Mayhem coming up next we have
Benny Maru versus
if I have to be perfectly honest this is
less of a fight and more of a dummy test
karibis was previously established to
not be taken lightly and this here is no
exception as previous episodes have
shown that even the three beasts along
with Guild and gabiru even had trouble
taking it down even receiving some
casualties on the whole ordeal so yes
this floating shark is still as strong
as ever even despite being an imitation
as things were Grim who else showed up
but Benny Maru descending into the
battlefield as he slices charybdis while
using his black flame to prevent it from
healing and in an instant engulfing the
entire Beast with hell flare and just
deleted it out of existence all that
within two moves may I remind you
karibdis who's been a huge obstacle for
the three beasts Guild and gabiru for
the past two days was just control all
deleted by Benny Maru using only two
moves if that doesn't establish the
power Dynamic then I don't know what
does Benny Maru has come so far to get
to this point and that should warrant a
little bit of flexing in my opinion so
long charitis she won't be missed
[Music]
May well be a nostalgic trip for you
the final fight between sooner and
vyakuran in Hitman Reborn was a
thrilling climax that showcased the
growth and determination of the
protagonist Suna sunayoshi who started
as a timid and clumsy teenager typical
for a Shonen protagonist had to overcome
his fears and doubts to unleash his full
potential as the vongola decimal our boy
turned from a cowardly Schoolboy to the
badass leader of one of the most
powerful mafia families in the anime
this whole journey in the anime was
mostly a flex so it shouldn't be a
surprise that his final fight with the
big bad that's been looming since the
start of the anime would be one of the
most memorable moments of the show the
fight was a clash of Wills skills and
ideals coupled with the animation that
was fluid and dynamic stunning effects
and a soundtrack that enhanced the
emotional impact of the scene battling
against the enemy who has the same
abilities as you are also being buffed
as hell and has a winning record in a
parallel Dimension you think the odds
would be stacked again sooner but of
course not this is a Shonen anime we're
talking about it's only right that his
ancestor who is the first ever of the
mafiath would appear and remove suna's
limiters he then proceeded to rip
biakuran's Wings off and after tragic
twists and turns deliver a final blow
with the full power of His ironic
x-burner overpowering his enemies Flames
while declaring his resolve to protect
his friends and family the fight was a
satisfying conclusion to the Future
final battle Arc and cement's reborn as
an often overlooked Shonen animate that
most deserved leads of remake
foreign
[Applause]
two elements clash in the next entry as
we talk about the final fight between
origami and Hitomi in the code breaker
anime
[Music]
fire and lightning are two sides of the
same coin if we're talking about their
coolness in anime the lightning user
Hitomi also appeared on one of our lists
when he single-handedly dealt with all
the code Breakers early on in the series
with olgummy the edgy fire user being
defeated by his teacher this cemented
hitomi's position as a strong and
compelling antagonist that the heroes
have to overcome it's comeuppance
arrived in the final episode where
origami releases his true power along
with an over-the-top flourish just for
removing his ring the scene oozes with
edginess as blue flames appear in the
shape of a serpent and an English voice
overlaps with his when ogami tells
Hitomi that he's gonna burn him up the
Azure Flames aren't just for sure and
hito me and the other code Breakers
realize the terrifying power when the
Flames effortlessly burn his white
lightning attacks you just know you're a
goner when you see blue fire just eating
up your lightning attacks and the guy
those Flames came from just stands
around there menacingly as much as the
anime ended up being somewhat of a
disappointment the scene sticks out as
one memorable Flex for an edgy fire user
[Music]
foreign
fate Grand order takes the stages coming
up next we have quetzal Koto
the face series really does love their
nuclear explosions as once again we're
treated to one of the most orgasmic and
satisfying Visual and sound designs that
the Fate series has to offer this scene
is a gorgeous spectacle an enormous Flex
in my opinion showing quetzal koto's
impressive nuking abilities not once but
twice her Noble Phantasm Piedra Del Sol
is very much indicative of her
capabilities and power as a servant as
it allows her to open up a gate that
gives her the ability to utilize her
authority over the literal Sun
unleashing a blast of solar wind in the
surrounding area evaporating not only
the grounded Liam what they're standing
on but also chaos tied along with him if
that City annihilating level of attack
isn't enough to impress you then fret
not as the party is just getting started
she also used Ultimo dope an extinction
level drop kick that imitates the very
same meteor that almost killed all life
on Earth if that Display of Power still
doesn't impress you then you also have
to keep in mind that she wasn't even in
her full power State when performing
those Noble phantasms she was nerfed so
hard so that she wouldn't convert the
entire continent in a pile of molten
slug yeah that's a flexor right
following that one-sided beat down we
have karon the reflector from fire force
the one coming up next is arguably one
of the coolest characters in the series
I know he's supposed to beat an
antagonist but it is unfair if you make
him this cool you might argue that he's
not a fire user but if you think about
it karon is still basically a fire user
in a sense due to his ability to
manipulate and control fire and that
reflector ability of his was presented
front and center in his confrontation
against nataku now in a berserk and
unstable State nautical was about to
blow everyone and their dog to Kingdom
come with this attack and that was
basically on par with that of an atomic
bomb and of course who's best to receive
such a lovely present other than the
reflector himself tanking the whole
blast using nothing but his fist and
sheer willpower absorbing the entirety
of the blast and reflecting it straight
to the Moon in terms of pure
unadulterated badassery this is surely
up there once again I present to you car
on the reflector and you better put some
respect on his name
foreign
list we have one of the most visually
stunning Chinese Anime created by
samsara Studios released in 2019 that's
right ladies and gentlemen it's the fog
Hill of five elements
the protagonist is a former aspect of
fire but former doesn't mean weaker as
his fight with the Beast of Wrath proves
it the power and martial prowess of the
aspect of the elements are shown here in
full display all the while supported by
The Marvelous animation and sound design
of samsara Studios this isn't only a
flex by the aspect of fire yushwon who
held his own against the quillian aka
the strongest demon but also the small
team of Chinese animators that prove
they have the passion and skill to make
a banger anime
thank you
and those are my second set of favorite
moments when fire uses Flex on their
opponents but again there are just so
many characters that can control flames
in anime there's bound to be some more
that I've missed let me know what you
think in the comment section below I'm
glad to have you here and thanks so much
again for watching this video